c'est les parents de kiss en
classe ils sont jaloux visas belges
entendu en faisant tuer ils sont beaux
ils
s'appellent delphine aussi parce qu'elle
est très jeune exactement et bien oui ce
sont les peuples cessé de papa et la
maman de delphine
j'aime bien très bon binôme franchement
faire les marques belges adorent
branchement ils sont très mignons voilà
ouais il ya derrière rose et derrière il
ya tout à fait
derrière toi
c'est dingue
c'est dans
c'était dingue c'est dingue ces derniers
sont là il est là ils sont là c'est
dingue ils sont très beaux les parents
d'un final très masse sympathique très
bon quand il s'entendait votre fiancée
bien bien bien ça c'est important parce
que ça aurait été beau parent c'est
malin qui a fait un nom au début c'est
un peu compliqué maintenant c'est très
bien ah oui on décide on a l'impression
que ça ne s'est pas compris pourquoi
et vous
oui ça me ramène à nouveau chéri à la
maison c'est toujours compliqué vous
imaginez bien l'avis de castaldi tous
les jours mais voilà donc c'est vrai que
c'est toujours compliqué de présenter
son chéri c'est compliqué papa et à son
vin de quoi la même âge que son père son
papa et sa maman femme et non pas son
regard des deuxième photo je pense que
vous allez trouver tout de suite que
c'est une photo de 1789
[Rires]
c'est les parents de daniel way sa
rigoureuse
tuerait
et et tes parents sont rien et on perd
et ses mots ouais ils étaient un millier
grand il était élancé
[Rires]
c'est l'émotion de voir ses parents
va fermer ta gueule bordel ils sont
magnifiques ce sens énormément à sa
maman mais tu es tu es magnifique et ta
maman est vraiment elle est pas belle
migraine magnifique vraiment magnifique
c'était daniel on n'a pas
à ton père
et ta maman c'est un
site on perd vraiment
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tout d'abord
photo
ça déconne et regarder alors ça c'est
beaucoup d'argent
mais ça
c'est dans quel à nice alors est-ce bon
dans les années cinquante cinq qui
venaient de suisse en 56
ans marié en cinq ans et veut donc tout
cas c'est foutrement mais c'était déjà
plus moderne que toi
manon massé nuria elle est toujours oui
oui elle est pas peut-être ça elle va
peut-être sa bannette ah ouais ben beh
préoccupations leurs voix seraient
fortement que j'adore non mais c'est
vrai est vraiment ils sont traités vous
adore mais c'est franchement magnifique
mais tu fais des gros bisous à la maman
de daniel et je sais qu'elle regarde
tous les soirs aime beaucoup et ça lui
fait du bien je le sais ça me fait
plaisir de lui faire du bien parce que
ça me fait plaisir de
faire du bien à sa fille un peu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais mon plaisir à ma mère c'est vrai
tous les soirs on va pas décevoir une
vieille dame
maintenant si ça
tous les soirs elle me demanda me dit ça
y est cyril fois les mre
concept vous aime beaucoup elle aimerait
qu'on sent ensemble vous avez tellement
un grand coeur
votre maman est vrai qu'ils n'ont pas
non mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un petit
moment il me disait que vous étiez un
peu de gendre idéal heures rigolo beau
gosse a ri chauffe avant
l'été sa paroisse
tant qu'homme chauffer ouais mais
franchement ça fait plaisir j'aime bien
moi je tâte allez voir votre mère à
qui reviendraient d'avoir ta gueule pas
ça très beau c'est peut-être je
demanderai votre main
[Rires]
il ya un protocole et oui non mais c'est
vrai daniel franchement j'aurais pu
embrasser très forte à maman tu sais que
c'est important pour moi bon ben c'est
les gens
regard des problèmes photo c'est le
moment de qui ça c'est la maman de
guillaume genton
bien sûr c'est la maman de béatrice
avec béatrice est allé voter comme et et
béatrice à côté
sans vraie belle merci très beau message
aussi non regardez non on passe à celui
d'après bas sur celui d'après c'est
facile regardez regardez regardez celui
d'après alors
bien sûr il est magnifique très jeune
mais vous vous ressemblez il est très
beau le père carrément traité mot
regarder un regard est comme il est beau
c'est franchement magnifique
incroyable on n'a pas notre photo ap
photo deux heures bordel ah ouais on
dirait que tu perds ton temps moins de
dix villes en plus beaux noms dans ton
père et plus beau ah bon pas moi nos
trésors ton père on était très beau film
et on perd là ton père je trouve
magnifique sans mal son fils un très bon
tu trouves le monde tombait bien son nom
c'est malade ou quoi enfin dernier par
an les danois les derniers par an
dernier par an le papa qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure si kleiza à m'arrêter un
guillaume genton les
garder
le
même coup
il donnait pas envie de ça se fait pas
il est sain mais qui n'est jovialité
la maman peut-être va vous mettre sur la
voie mais
son père et sa mère sont en même temps
les papas mamans
le en même temps le papa et la maman les
grands
ça c'est le papa et la maman
de lourdes et papa comblé voulait voir
ses les deux voies n'allez pas en bio il
ressemble plus à sa maman
[Rires]
c'est pas vrai
il faut pas que ce soit et je
vous dis que c'est le
papa non c'est pas bon du tout pour ça
qu'on rigolait
pour les mecs c'est pas censé
en plus pour mettez le papa de guillaume
[Rires]
guillaume
ce ne sont pas ses parents les gens que
j'aime beaucoup voilà que ça existe
vraiment oui bah oui
je l'embrassé qui sont extrêmement
sympathique voilà merci à eux d'être
parmi nous ce soir
sans la
voir là quoi ils sont là en photo à gr